قال رئيس الاوكراني في نادي نسكي ان هناك
نحو تسعه ملايين اوكراني بلا كهرباء جراء
ضربات الروسيه على بنيه التحتيه في البلاد
اضاف زنكي ان الروس يضغطون بكل امكانياتهم
ومواردهم في اقليم اريدون باسني تحقيق ما
وصفه ببعض التقدم في تلك الجبهات
باي باي
اقصى قدر من القوه التركيز الوضع هناك صعب
يضغط المحتلون بكل امكانياتهم لتحقيق بعض
التقدم هناك اشكر جميع رجالنا الذين يقفون
في مواقعهم بقوه ويجدون الفرصه لضرب
المحتلين وتقلي لاعدادهم عقدت اجتماعا
خاصا مع المسؤولين الحكوميين بشان الطاقه
تهديدات علينا حلها وهناك خطوات يجب
اتخاذها كما عقلت اجتماعا موسعا بشان
نتائج زياره الى الولايات المتحده لن نضيع
الوقت سننفذ بسرعه كل ما تم الاتفاق عليه
في واشنطن